♪♪
You may think that luck is just
random,
but in our new film, you'll
discover that
Jane Fonda:
there's an entire world
dedicated to creating the luck we experience every day.
Wait, they actually think up the
good luck?
Yeah.
The land of luck isn't all
sunshine and rainbows.
Ow!
I mean, sure. There is lots of
sunshine and the occasional
rainbow.
It's really nice, actually.
♪♪
But, that's only because there's
rules.
Good luck to us both.
♪♪
For instance, good luck
creatures can only travel to and
from the human world
Eva Noblezada:
using a lucky penny.
Elf Manager:
Let's get these pennies in tip
top shape.
Which by the way, you must
always return upon arrival.
Elf Manager:
Everyone knows the punishment
for stealing good luck is banishment to bad luck.
Another important rule: when it
comes to bad luck, avoid it at
all costs.
If you don't she'll know.
(Sniffs and exclaims)
Rabbits!
She always does.
Ahh, much better.
And above all else, no humans
allowed.
Ahh!
Sam & Bob:
(Scream)
If a human ever stepped foot in
the Land of Luck...
It'd be bad.
♪♪
(Exclaims)
Oh this can't be happening.
♪♪
Ahh!
(Sigh) Yikes.
Learn more about the Land of
Luck when the new Apple Original
Film, "Luck" hits Apple TV+,
August 5th.
This is the moment we've all
been waiting for.